they were in one of those tubes this kid
pushes him and then I see Caitlyn doing
this
he's probably three
she puts Caitlyn at five and a half or
six this boy was 10.
she's going like this and he goes
and she just goes
his face turned my way in the window and
it was just
tears coming out of this kid's face you
know what she did
she hugged him
they came back down to the table like
okay what was that and she goes well he
was picking on Jacob and I told him you
don't pick on my brother you don't pick
on my brother and he goes what are you
gonna do and she go she goes he asked me
that so I showed him
she said she hugged him and said you'll
win a fight someday
[Applause]
nasty